for recording
the axa sa 17 11 runs yes
i think this variant is called a variant
yes that has brought a lot for
black
well yes good now we have different
options you can just
make 4 or g3 or normal moves
the country is but maybe  also to
take on the 6 that is actually a
very good structure creates a follower 64
and R&D could michael be because of the
point here so the player the 453
ed4 because you can also try jumper g5
maybe then continue very
aggressively with h3 or something like that jumper  ag 5
h 6
6 of
course looks ugly
or bid with it
I'll try that here or there
six who doesn't play it I just have
h3
six then I have any other
moves so apart from game 4 now just the ones
that wouldn't do otherwise
yes i thought hard now 33
yes but the thing i thought i now
should actually be a very good
structure reference to a hard
line of very weak  e point on e6 they are
quite dangerous except for black
yes we develop maybe that way
he still has a bit of
difficulties here with the
development himself or he does something like the
vc 1 toren 10 16 to almost speed you up a
bit
then  but if i had the train g5 which
i think might be kind of uncomfortable
but then he actually has
to get back to it somehow that saves
energy 4 doesn't actually look like the
kids then go there so easy
the idea was to play safari 4 now when he was operating
but  the power of the
media also demands here in the
position
i think they get if the
jumper 50 lady me here that was a
bit unusual the lady in the
middle but he can’t get rid of her
i think at least
that depends but a seven is
also  c 54 times an idea I
apart from the fact that h are still
depends
yes what does it do now anyway
with that yes back then 26
w55 jumpers  the five cd 7 must
actually be good white so 25 cds inks of
course so yes well not allow the five
so now was a donation 15 should
actually go the simple 6
but didn’t do that and now 36 what’s coming
but here you can go something ok
Of course not but should actually
be good right
now just next to the 1 and
then there are others or jumper four
jumper is even a stronger threat
I was there before like four
died
because I jump here should actually
be deadly now or he makes it
there we have five or so
yes it can actually be bad
so yes they are allowed to swap with it
part but
try to exploit active knothe delivery so
naturally with his chrome
looking like tom f3dm won the three top 11 3
but really great answer then
not at all yes that was the only
thing i think i have to step on the
gas a bit it was a farmer and
a good stim  mung but not much time
well with a second
well yes yes yes I was in it more
than this stupid endgame pawns more
but somehow I didn't get it
with less time